good morning everybody I hope everyone's
got coffee and as people have heard
we're recording this this is going to be
put on our web and we're actually doing
this I have a acknowledgments light at
the end the support from some associates
especially the man foundation and the
far fund and it's an effort to get
information out to audiences that need
it and in this case I'm talking about
autism for primary care providers I
should say my conflicts of interest
which are various books and the Journal
of autism and a couple of foundation
grants so I'm going to say a little bit
today about what is autism this is again
a very generic discussion for primary
care providers if they're interested
they will hear they will hear right now
that there's a whole set of lectures on
iTunes U or YouTube that they can go in
access which gets in a much more of the
details and the weeds on all this I want
to say a little bit about autism is a
social learning disorder something about
screening and diagnosis which is an
important and slightly controversial
topic was early enough and then say
something about medical issues and how
autism's treated changes over time and
then some references so here's the man
who first described autism 1943 we've
talked about 11 children who came into
the world without the usual
predisposition to be social which is
really critical for many aspects of what
I'm about to say today he also talked
about these were children who had
trouble with change and it's interesting
when you think about it it's actually
the basis of much of our work these days
on the one hand he's saying these are
children who have not much interest in
the social world but they're kind of
overly unchristian in on social world
and it's trying to make sense out of
that which drives a lot of our research
he thought children were born with
autism and he also was careful to talk
about some developmental issues he
actually talked about the work of our
own gizelle who was then here at Yale
and who said that by six weeks babies
were smiling back and forth to their
parents and Connor mentioned this to
emphasize how this was often autism the
babies weren't so interested their
parents we actually now know that from
the moment of birth the typical baby is
profoundly interested in their parents
so autism first and foremost is a social
learning disability and in fact that
some in some ways it's a better way to
get into it than talking about all the
various a words autism Asperger's cause
it's more understandable for the general
population it shares many
characteristics with other disabilities
and general people don't outgrow it all
they could be tremendously helped and
often are but not always are with a
realization of what their strengths and
weaknesses are it differs from other
disabilities because of its early onset
and its pervasive effects and that's the
part of the funny pervasive
developmental disorder that was true if
you come into the world with a social
learning problem everything is off in
terms of how you learn about the world
and that causes major major troubles we
know a lot about how autism actually our
understanding of autism has changed over
time in the 1950s all the way into the
70s parents were blamed for causing
autism parents was thought that they
didn't treat their children ride they
were not neglecting them they were
something was going off psychotherapy
was used this started to change after
about 20 years of the 1970s there was a
strong brain connection I'm going to say
more about strong genetic connection
connection and also was discovered that
structured teaching was more effective
than unstructured psychotherapy and the
first of the various school programs in
this country and around the world were
started because public schools at that
point did not have to take children with
autism and often refused to do so so
parents started their own schools these
schools like Ben Haven here in town the
Grodin Center in Rhode Island places
around the country that started off
because parents were trying to get
education for their children the thing
that really changed this which is really
important to realize is public law
94-142 which established in this country
in 1976 the right to a free and
appropriate education for all children
with vulnerabilities schools could no
longer refuse turn away children with
older abilities they had to educate
everyone this was actually part of a
whole civil rights movement some of the
language is actually civil rights
language when you read the law which is
now morphed into something called I DEA
I mentioned some of the brain aspects of
autism this was one of the things that
really convinced people that autism was
a brain based disorder the green bar
shows data from Cooper which is a study
of I think about 5,000 British
typically-developing as a normal sample
normative sample of children rates of
onset of epilepsy recurrent seizures not
just one seizure recurrent seizures
epilepsy and the age is less than 3 3 to
6 years 7 to 10 it's set for etc and you
can see that for the typical population
onset of seizures is greatest early in
life and then goes down down
down by the time you're 15 or so years
of age less than one of the thousand
children is developing seizures for the
first time in any of you in this room
and they probably the mean ages in their
twenties were to develop a seizure for
the first time you'd be worked up the
wazoo because people are looking to see
what the world is causing this it's so
unusual kids with autism have an
increased risk you see that in both the
two light and blue dark blue bars the
dark blue is from a sample we had here
about 500 children with autism that we
medical student followed up with me and
the other is a sample from Boston Dyke
ins and McMahon but you can see across
the board elevated risk for kids on the
autism spectrum and in fact an onset not
only an early childhood but again in
adolescence otherwise a very unusual
time I have a lady I've taken care of
for many years now who's probably in her
late 50s who just had her first seizure
a few years ago and sadly we don't know
much about when the seizures onset after
this is this is the sum total of our
knowledge really about seizure onset but
it is cause some some people as adults
also develop seizures genetics I
mentioned was also a major thing in
1970s the first twin study was done by
Mike Rutter and Susan full-steam that
looked at identical monozygotic versus
dizygotic twins and discovered a very
high rate of concordance among identical
twins much higher than the fraternal
twins over time many different
strategies have been used to look now at
the genetics of autism tremendous
advances have been made it's gotten very
interesting and very complicated and
very confusing I hope the same time
autism is clearly a very complicated
disorder with many genes involved many
of these genes seem to have some aspect
of regulating either brain nerve
connection or something else about brain
connectivity we also know interesting
that there's an increased risk for
siblings and recurrence we
underestimated that this at first
probably the recurrence risk in siblings
is in the order of 10 to 20 percent so
having had one child with autism you're
a chance of having a second is increased
statistically over the population I was
just out of New York giving a talk and
somebody was saying they seen a family
with five children with autism I said oh
I know a family with fudge roll that has
turned out to be the same family by 1980
there was increased understanding and
autism was recognized as this or Durance
it's included as a diagnosis we also had
the first model treatment program start
to develop over the 1990s has been
really an explosion of research the
first practice guidelines came out where
there was enough information to tell
people something about this this is why
the standard of practice should be for
looking for screening for looking and
caring for children with autism there
was a great report that came out in 2001
from the National Research Council I'll
say a little more about this at the end
which looked at it's called educating
children with autism it looked at 10
model programs around the country each
of which had at least one published
paper in a peer-reviewed journal to show
that the model worked and there are many
commonalities some differences but there
was a general consensus that early
intervention made a big difference over
time has been a much more work in terms
of research but also parents have gotten
much more involved parent groups are not
tremendously active a public awareness
has increased also substantially their
ads on the television way back when
there was a movie Rain Man which was
groundbreaking there's an increased body
of work on evidence-based interventions
we'll talk more about and there have
been more and more attempts to integrate
research into clinical practice also
there's been a tremendous emphasis on
screening and work with young children I
have to say as an aside and this is not
irrelevant to primary care doctors
unfortunately research especially on
school but especially on adolescent and
older individuals with autism has really
lagged so there's almost there's almost
no work on older individuals with autism
there's literally almost no work on
aging in autism sadly over the time of
since Connors first work there's been an
evolution of the concept of autism as a
diagnosis this has gone through from DSM
3 all the way to dsm-5 an autism
spectrum for primary care doctors it's
probably not so critical to worry about
this let me say a bit though why is
autism a problem for learning if you
come into the world like most of us do
you have a social frame you look at the
world in the context of other people
you're interested in knowing what other
people thinking feeling wanting doing
how can I tell people what I want think
feeling do if you go to play the social
game people the center of your world you
get something called joint attention
that kicks in very quickly that you
learn from looking at what your parents
are look
that's what's really relevant in the
world not everything else you also have
a strong desire to communicate and you
really start to sort out the world
starting with people we know a lot about
how the social brain works and again for
the primary care doctors it's important
only to know that we've identified parts
of the brain that are involved in things
like face processing perception of
biological motion understanding of other
people empathy emotional feelings
anxiety we've used many different
methods to look at this looking at
understanding the face both through EEG
and MRI I'm gonna give some examples of
that perception of biological motion and
MRI perception of emotion looking at
things like the amygdala and how it
responds and processing social
information through things like eye
tracking this is a slide from dr.
McPartlin looking at evoke response
potentials and faces and again you can
see that the typical population for
individuals with autism there's an
obvious difference in terms of AEG
processing which speaks to different
methods for looking at faces we also
know and this is a study that was done
some years ago here and which happily
has been replicated more than 20 times
people with autism don't seem to use the
same part of their brain the fusiform
gyrus that's the rest of us do for
processing faces and it's a very
striking finding as I say it works
really extremely well and has been
replicated many times now we also know
from some work on eye tracking the
people with autism seem to look at the
world in different ways this has gotten
much more interesting since our original
study Tasha and Fred have looked at this
we've looked at this and again people
around the world have looked at this the
effect size in our first paper on this
was tremendous in terms of looking at
the eyes in the face people with autism
as you see at the bottom tend to look
back and forth at the mouth in this
first study and people who were
typically developing looked more at the
eyes this was a very strong a very high
magnitude effect and again what does
always speak to if you don't have the
social frame everything else is
important you don't know how to regulate
what is and isn't important what you get
is all kinds of stuff happening and you
have to sort out what does it all mean
so you work for things like contingency
a happens B happens it happens behalf
so you really are resorting to another
level of analysis and it doesn't work so
well sadly so what does this meaning the
meaning sought through under sought
through connectivity you have
difficulties with multitasking you don't
have joint attention you have limited
incidental learning you have things like
in your voice persistent odd sounds
because you're not interested in
processing with sounds and other people
are making this makes for major problems
in learning I want to say a word about
best practices this comes back to haunt
us sometimes I say this is the author of
practice parameters also author who book
on evidence-based treatments there are
many levels of evidence the best kinds
of evidence we have in medicine or
randomized controlled trials that's not
always so easy to do when you're looking
at school programs not totally
impossible but it's it's a hard thing to
do we also like to look at meta analyses
and if you look at some of the recent
practice guidelines from the United
Kingdom they want at least they want
multiple randomized controlled trials
and at least one meta-analysis and again
that's a lot to ask for especially at a
time when a research funding is so
little from that level we go down to
uncontrolled studies case reports and
anecdote
there are different guidelines that use
different approaches you have to be
careful about looking at what their
guidelines are the Brits are very
careful to talk about their levels of
evidence and what it means and again to
know that evidence-based medicine is not
quite the same thing as evidence-based
practice evidence-based practice we need
to look at all the data and the person
the person's values their needs and try
to sort out what is best for them that
means that we should we can use things
that have perhaps not the strongest
evidence because that's the best we got
also keep in mind that for
evidence-based medicine
evidence-based practice when we look at
really well-done studies we're going to
have very strict subject selection that
of course throws everything off because
in the real world people aren't that way
you want to do a study of autism and X
well you start excluding people with
autism and seizures you start excluding
people with autism below a certain IQ
the next thing you know you've got a
very small sample it's great to study
it's not necessarily representative of
the world and there is this potential
for a catch-22 where we have for example
insurance company might say well it's
not evidence-based well it's not
evidence base because
just gotten started or we're just doing
research so we have to be careful to
have some sense about this also let me
emphasize some studies have never been
done but the intervention is totally
accepted and I can show you one example
this has never been proven to work in a
randomized controlled trial and yet
people still do it all the time if you
had the choice of jumping out of the
airplane with or without the parachute
which one would you take right so again
it sounds a little trivial but it's not
it's actually profound keep in mind
there were some things will never ever
be able to show in a randomized
controlled trial this is going to come
back to us talking about screening which
is what why I put this in we know that
below age five years children probably
have the greatest potential for
tremendous gain the presumption is that
for many although not all early
intervention can make a major difference
and I emphasize not all some kids in
very good programs for reasons we don't
always understand don't always do so
well but some do and for some children
it's night and day difference we see a
child at two-and-a-half I literally have
videos for two and a half year old
spinning around my office by five euros
of aged child was talking the kid is now
15 and doing stand-up comedy there's a
again many issues in early diagnosis we
know that not always are we sure until
about age three although often we have
very strong presumptions the usual
problem we face and work with very young
children is that Shaun may have the
social and communication problems that
we see in autism but not yet the sort of
full-fledged troubles with change body
rocking etc the latter often emerge by
age three after before age three we know
that we can get services through birth
to three four primary care providers in
this country they should know that after
age three the school district will kick
it under public law 94-142 and its
successor ID a until the child is 21
years of age people know that there are
various kinds of screeners type one
screeners are looking for general
developmental delay the American Academy
of Pediatrics recommends this at nine
eighteen and thirty months type two
screeners are more specific to certain
disorders so for autism the American
Academy of Pediatrics has recommended
screening at 18 and 24 months using the
m-chat and that's looking just for
autism we'll talk about what the issues
are within chat in just a second having
a diagnosis of autism often get you the
levels of support from both birth to
three and the schools and again for the
primary care provider to realize the
schools have the major responsibility
for intervention now the problem the
problem is we have somewhat conflicting
recommendations at the moment the
American Academy of Pediatrics and the
American Academy of Child and Adolescent
Psychiatry very recently have said yes
we should screen on the other hand the
US Preventive service task force that
it's drafted last year but about to
become final says well it's not so clear
that the screening works it's not so
clearly would have great data on the
early intervention all of it's true and
the but and the but is but you're
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
the downside to screening they pointed
out is she'll pick up in a lot of kids
with other developmental problems which
I would say not necessarily so bad but
that's kind of the controversy at the
moment the real problem is picking up
false positives so what do we do well I
think it's important to continue to
screen and certainly if I were going to
a primary care doctor I'd want my child
a grandchild screened and I'd want
follow-up and you want to share any
concerns with the parents so the parents
are involved in thinking about and
tracking the issues and of course being
aware of autism is a problem so the
warning signs before from birth to a
year and this is adapted from a chapter
caution I did a few years ago there's
some social symptoms communication
symptoms and restricted interest this is
a relatively short list below age one
and of course part of the problem is
it's harder to assess things below age
one after age one the expectations
developmentally begin to increase so
that after age one from 12 to 36 months
it takes me two slides to show some of
the warning signs so here are the social
ones and some communication ones and
again you can see these are just in more
details some of the same themes we
elaborated early on and also restricted
interests we have more actual explicit
problems in the area of restricted
interests and the other thing to
emphasize is regression regression at
any point in development is a warning
flag and for pediatricians to hear that
about 20% of parents of children with
autism will report the child has
regressed you have to look into this
very carefully but it's a warning
sighted really
be something investigated early
screening guidelines I mentioned level
one screening guidelines are routine
developmental screening level two is
more in-depth for children at risk and
the hope there is to differentiate
children who might be having autism from
other developmental disorders there are
a number of very good screeners I have a
reference at the end to a chapter that
reviews them well it's quite current
some are quite specific to autism some
are based on parent report others on
observation at present all are paper and
pencil we don't have something like a
hearing test for autism although there's
a lot of interest in developing some
such keep in mind they all have their
limitations and uses as well as their
liabilities the m-chat was probably the
most commonly used it was developed by
diana Robbins who was a student here
also student of Debbie finds is one of
the co-authors it's a 23 items'
checklist
it best discriminates at 24 months the
items that especially discriminate are
the proto declared a point uh uh showing
something I want you to see that clock
responding to name and twisting other
children bringing objects to show
following a point imitations social
smile one of the things that's really
important when the child screen is
positive is to do follow-up the trouble
at the end chat is it gets many false
negatives it has a higher specificity
even there it misses some children and
again it's for complicated reasons
sometimes the child is higher function
sometimes the child regresses sometimes
the parent report is off all those usual
things and I should point out by the way
that there are many problems even when
people use this there was a large study
from California looking I think it's 17
pediatric practices even when kids score
positive about 60% of the time nothing
ever happened as a result things fell
through the cracks the parent was told
to contact birth to 3 but they didn't or
they content the birth to 3 in bracelets
we didn't call back so keep in mind as
well that's important for the
pediatrician or the primary care
provider to be sure there's follow-up if
a child does screen positive there's a
new version of the EM chat that's
relatively shortly out it has low middle
and high risk groups the middle group is
this or a tricky one in terms of knowing
what to do there's a nice study on it
and again it's it's better done than the
earlier
I am chat it still requires a certain
amount of thought clinically when using
it but it's important to have some
screen or out there that you're
positively using we have new approaches
that are in the offing to develop
screening methods these would use things
like EEG eye tracking listening
these have many potential advantages the
problems with these at the moment and
cost you eye nose unfortunately sick
today so as she's done here I could talk
about this in some detail the problem is
most of these studies are being
developed using high risk samples and if
you have a high risk sample if you're
looking at siblings who are developing
you're basically fishing in a stocked
pond as they say and so what we need to
do is take these out into the real world
which is always the problem with
treatments and methods developed in
clinical settings like this research one
is to go out in the real world okay how
well is this really work and not just in
the general population but children with
developmental disabilities and people
know that we're very aware of these
issues as we look for new approaches to
screening there are a number of other
screeners available I've listed a couple
here these can be used they require
various levels of training I also would
emphasize and I'm not talking about it
in this talk
there are also screening approaches for
older children adolescents and adults
and we do occasionally have children who
come in who've never been diagnosed to
her school age even older and there was
a recent study I think was Virginia Tech
looking a large sample of undergraduates
just basically literally pulled off the
screen about 1 to 2 percent of them
screen positive for autism either on the
SS SRS or another autism screener so
there probably are cases that are indeed
underlooked parent and perception can
impact screening it's not diagnostic
having a positive screen does not mean
you necessarily have autism it's a
problem also from any primary care
physicians and providers seeing children
in highly unusual settings like the
pediatric office you're not going to see
representative behavior either the kid's
gonna be a mess and out of control or
totally withdrawn and bonkers and
waiting for the next shot it's a problem
and that's why it's it's good to get
parent report but keep in mind that all
this has its limitations parents who are
more educated and sophisticated may see
more they also may report more parents
who have less education less aware of
autism
not appreciate what's going on there's
good data on that sadly in terms of what
we want to do in terms of an assessment
we want to have a history for everybody
looking at pre perinatal developmental
histories how the child is doing at the
moment the family history or other
people the family who have autism other
developmental problems other psychiatric
issues it turns out anxiety and
depression are often seen in family
members and regression as I mentioned is
always a warning sign that should prompt
worth studying initial assessments there
are practice guidelines and actually
give very specific recommendations
basically you're looking hearing and
vision dysmorphic features the genetic
degree of genetic evaluation as people
heard recently when allah gave a talk is
a area of some controversy at the moment
any dysmorphic features especially with
family history should prompt a more
in-depth genetic assessment also be
aware of the more frequent medical
problems seizures and a couple of
associated medical conditions fragile x
tuberous sclerosis and there's a host of
other things that are kicking around at
a very low level of the genetic variety
that also need to be aware of the
history we look at the pregnancy labor
and delivery developmental milestones
family history as time goes on we want
to hear about interventions medical
interventions complementary and
alternative treatments and what's
happened to the child over time have
there been major changes regression or
moves to the better the two times you
hear about changes major changes early
childhood and again adolescents some
kids in early childhood take off others
don't
some kids and adolescents take off and a
few sadly a few don't do so well they go
to the other direction
physical exam again you're looking for
genetic conditions that might go along
with fragile x tuberous sclerosis so
unusual physical features on exam it
needs it's more features at all
questions of seizure disorder head size
and the interesting thing about head
size which is seen a microcephaly has
seen in a minority of people with autism
and cautious work has pointed out that
it actually may be a more generic
generic problem not just head size but
body size as well these are big kids
laboratory studies led level the genetic
testing I mentioned is going genetic se
has gotten very sophisticated what used
to be extremely expensive and
complicated has gotten much cheaper but
not totally
expensive it's guided by history and
exam and the recommendations from the
American College of genetics are
published they do not endorse the
current commercially available gene
panels which is probably important for
pediatricians to know none of the
practice guidelines by the way also
endorsed things like hair testing the
vitamin business there's just not
evidence for it and AG only if the
history suggests regression or signs and
physical exam neuroimaging interestingly
does not feel much pay off on a routine
basis obviously if there were
indications yes but routinely no the 20%
of seizures the risk persists into
adolescence fragile x tuber sclerosis
the yield when you start doing very
sophisticated testing genetically is
about ten percent at most sometimes this
is uninterpretable and sometimes it has
real importance for the family hearing
and vision screening should always be
done the medical home is something
that's been recommended by the American
Academy of Pediatrics especially for
children with special needs it suggested
should be a care program that's
comprehensive coordinated accessible
family-centered people should know what
they're doing they should know about
resources they should really be a
resource for the family for children
with autism and fortunate care is often
very fragmented they have trouble
getting services they have trouble
finding primary care providers who have
good knowledge they often use the
emergency room as a resource they failed
to look at the big picture so for
example it's easy to skip dental visits
dental visits are they're one of the
easiest things to skip and you often pay
a horrible price in adolescence as kids
start to have to have general anesthesia
to have dental work done of any kind and
that's also a problem with dental
problems really kicking in a major way
comprehensive assessments this is the
kind of thing we do here at the trail
Study Center this is not something a
pediatrician or the primary care
provider would do in their office we're
looking at doing a developmental
assessment or IQ test for an older child
we recommend speech communication
assessment as part of an exam
psychiatric assessment including
diagnostic instruments the latter do not
replace ever good clinical judgment I
was just talking to Kathy Lord about
this who was we were agreeing about a
case that you know you do the
instruments but then you take a step
back and say okay what does this tell us
about this child
other things like neurological and
medical and other professionals like
occupational
physical therapy can be very helpful the
label is important in this country
because it helps to get services states
vary somewhat in terms of when you have
to assign a specific diagnostic label
educational labels differs somewhat from
medical labels you can have very generic
labels like other health impaired or in
this state you can have developmentally
delayed I think still six Karin will
know five other states at various the
age in terms you can just have a generic
label the problem that's good the good
news is you don't have to label a child
you've not to say autism the bad news is
that should not become a reason for not
giving services and so that's the
discussion about the autism label
schools are mandated that mandated to
provide services autumn is autism is
specifically mentioned as one of the
handicapping conditions state
requirements vary I say widely and
wildly and that's absolutely true one of
the sad problems that's set issues in
this country we spend a lot of time we
think collecting data nobody can tell us
what's going on between the 50 states
it's hard enough even within a state the
Medicaid data from state to state is
almost uninterpretable and it's a shame
because we really have 50 different
experiments going on in the 50 states
and we don't know medical care issues
well child visits are very important it
helps to show of the staff become
familiar with each other you can make
visits go better by having visuals books
schedules and again there's a whole set
of resources that you can find online
for this help they help by making the
setting familiar you can have the child
go and spend time even when he's not
necessarily going for being sick so
that's why again why whelchel visits are
helpful for the physician or the nurse
practitioner you know keep things slow
keep language simple I'll talk more
about that in a second
same thing with dental visits and again
there's a little resource online the
same group of lectures on autism for
dentists that may be helpful having them
medical home is it make a difference
well in fact there's a number of papers
out now over the last years it says it
makes a big difference for kids with
autism one paper shows that there's
better coordination of care people tap
into more and more relevant services
another paper looking more generally at
children with developmental disabilities
and medical home settings
it actually decreases the number of
emergency room visits people are less
likely to use the IDI as their primary
care place one study says there are
fewer unmet needs people feel like
they're getting services in a medical
home and that study only 20% of the
sample were actually in medical home and
as Hyman has pointed out there are many
challenges to providing this this is not
something that's necessarily easy to
build although there have been efforts
to actually provide extra reimbursement
for providing a medical home model of
care in the primary care setting again
we talked about picture books apps
social stories thinking about scheduling
having the kid be the first appointment
the afternoon in the morning as opposed
to waiting waiting is not a plus having
favorite activities with using the iPad
to show that doctor's office ahead of
time the staff say more intrusive things
for the end ask for help from schools
and parents in terms of what works well
and again there are a number of
resources that are now available
interestingly enough a whole set of
books from the Royal College of
Psychiatry on things like having your
first GYN appointment picture books so
she can go through ahead of time so the
child knows what's going to happen
technology is extremely helpful on this
both low-tech pictures schedules other
kinds of things but the apps the mini
apps for the iPad and the iPhone can be
really helpful in terms of showing the
person what's gonna happen during the
doctor visit who's a doctor what's
what's what are we going to see are the
common problems you see in terms of what
gives people grief kids with autism have
problems with organization so you can be
stepwise you can be consistent you can
do the same thing every time you use
routines use visual aids you get plenty
of time you give visual cues we've got
three more things to do two more things
to do one more thing we're all done
isolate information in terms of
attentional skills saying this is we
need I need to listen to your heart
right now showing people giving
supporting attention having things again
visually predictable using visual
learnings and supports keeping language
simple one of the problems for all of us
as we talk to people who are getting
anxious we tend to get polite when we
get polite we tend to use things like
subjunctives could you might you should
you and that's bad we want to keep
things simple stop
now I'm doing this don't go through a
whole big package keep the language
simple and straightforward again people
with autism tend to learn things in
chunks that's one of the reasons they
often echo language if their style of
learning is don't learn the whole thing
as opposed to breaking it down so having
the family involved having them play at
home with things knowing about playing
doctor listening in the stethoscope
having a sense of what's going to happen
making things familiar as opposed to
anxiety provoking again in terms of time
temporal cues getting very
straightforward feedback showing timers
all kinds of things you can use to help
keeping things simple socially
understanding that social cues may be
very hard for kids to take in but be
very explicit in terms of what you're
going to do one of the important things
for primary care providers for all
children is helping parents around
safety issues accidents are the leading
cause of death in this country of
children and that same thing as true for
kids in the autism spectrum except the
rate is double the highest accidents
occur early on poisoning other kinds of
things
but you have a combination of good motor
skills and poor judgment and odd
interests and responses to things so the
kid may eat something to drink something
other kids wouldn't there's about a 40%
risk of bolting children who run out of
the house
I've had several sad examples in New
York City of kids who bolted from school
and were found in the river drowning is
the most common cause of death so you
want a safety proof the house be
prepared for problem solved
everybody should learn to swim for some
children who really have a tendency to
bolt having a good behavioral
psychologist you can consult around that
also having tracking devices there are
things you can have the kid wear now you
can have a little thing that kids got on
their arm or wear around their neck but
something that you can use to find the
child also meting alert bracelet it says
what the name is what I am autism but
again things like that thinking that the
safety is a real issue sleep problems
are extremely frequent more than half of
people with autism will have a sleep
problem that lasts more than a month the
common problems you see people don't
have good what's called sleep hygiene
they don't have good bedtime routines
they often unfortunately because they're
pure issues lack exercise they they
don't have the same amount of
sighs other kids do I think I have side
effects of medications that can throw
off the sleep cycle the kinds of things
you can do is you can keep a sleep diary
in fact it's interesting parents often
find the under report that bad in fact
the sleep problems are there's some very
good resources is a great book called
sleep better by a man named Mark Durand
was a behavioral psychologist it's a
great book on teaching sleep hygiene
looking at some simple things like
increasing exercise decreasing naps in
the daytime looking at the medications
having a very explicit sleep routine to
go through with a child having rituals
around night time and getting the kid to
sleep eating and GI problems these are
very commonly reported unusual food
preferences and sensitivities as kids
get older obesity is a major problem
these are kids who tend to enjoy food
because it's one of the few things that
they can get to and sadly because
they're socially isolated they often
don't have that peer interaction they
don't run around they can have problems
with eating non-nutritive substances pie
cup they can have constipation again
because they're not moving around so
much
there are many dietary interventions out
there proposed the evidence actually is
quite weak for these unfortunately the
gluten-free casein-free diet has been
evaluated as have been vitamins in a
couple of studies and there's just not
information to show that it works
there's a good double-blind study that's
just coming out if it hasn't come out
already in and she had a challenge study
looking a see if we diet didn't see any
difference and there's no evidence GI
problems are unique children with autism
dental care again starting early people
tend to avoid dental care all of us
avoid going to the dentist if we can
help it but preventing cavities even
simple things like fluoride teaching
about tooth brushing finding a good
pediatric dentist who will deal with a
child with special needs is important if
you can do it if you don't the trouble
hits you in adolescence often requiring
general general anesthesia one of the
commonest signs of dental problems in
adolescents who are non-verbal
is face-slapping because what's
happening is they're getting impacted
wisdom teeth or wasn't either coming in
but there are they having dental caries
but self-injurious behavior with rapid
onset is often include either for a
hearing in fact hearing ear infection or
dental issue
preschool issues medical issues have
finding a medical home getting services
screening getting a diagnosis the
transition from preschool to school
programs can be somewhat tricky around
age three behavior problems can start to
increase as so we get a little older it
can be more hard to manage
what's cute in a two or three year old
and a five or six year old my Nolan can
be cute and it may be quite problematic
under five years I mentioned is the time
for the child to make the greatest gains
kids continue to make gains after that
sadly not every child makes games
although some do many do by school age
we're talking a lot about preventive
care and routine visits dental care
vaccinations we want to look for things
like obesity side effects of medications
which can sometimes contribute that
safety issues and this is a time when
bullying starts to kick in about 40% of
children with autism in this country
report or apparently involved in
bullying in some way being bullied
themselves doing bullying sometimes or
both that's about double the national
rate which is about 20% if you're a
person with autism and you have other
problems as you go into adolescence your
rate of bullying it may be as high as 75
to 80% which is fairly tremendous as I
mentioned adolescents and adults we have
relatively little information in terms
of medical management issues and we have
basically none on Aging we do think that
probably the use of medications which
sadly is frequent and sometimes over
medication seems to be the rule as
opposed to the exception I think there
was a study done some years ago looking
at Medicaid populations I'm gonna say in
North Carolina and I may be wrong about
that but as I recall the typical person
was on three something medications and
by the time you passed two medications
it gets really hard to get involved
medications for behavior hypertension
starts to increase interesting among the
more cognitive able students we see a
college and beyond adolescents and young
adults there's an increased risk for
anxiety and depression and I mentioned
the bullying this is all unfortunately
often a package together they're all so
sad the issues with insurance coverage
and support especially as children age
out of their parents insurance policies
after age 26 many folks have to go on
Medicaid because that's all they're
eligible for drug treatments we have an
interestingly
major placebo effect in autism which
people do including me didn't think we
had until we did the studies this was
because we looked at a drug called
secretin which was a gut hormone people
were shirk here at autism there are five
double-blind studies very quickly done
secretin work know better than placebo
but placebo worked pretty damn well you
see how could that happen well of course
what's the placebo effect people are
paying more attention to the child and
they're expecting more from the shell
they're involved as expectancy effects
in terms of being involved in a study
people's behavior gets better that's
great news that tells us we can do a lot
even without the medication but a but it
really effective medication we want to
go past that and there have been a
couple of groups of medications I
emphasize only a couple that have really
been looked at with some in some depth
and detail in autism
risperidone and another one of the newer
generation second generation or eliptic
have been looked at they work pretty
well on quickly the SSRIs are used more
for anxiety and depression and to some
extent rigidity they seem to work
somewhat less well than children but
better in adolescents and adults and
there but it's several well done studies
in adults as with any medication you
always have to worry about the side
effect profile balancing the risk and
benefit this is the first RUP study
looking at risperidone this was a
double-blind placebo-controlled study
and what you can see here is by two
weeks there was a significant difference
between the groups
this difference continued and even
continued after risperidone was stopped
but I think six months follow-up now the
trouble with risperidone sedation is a
major side effect especially weight gain
it directly stimulates appetite and so
again you got a balance because you've
already got a population at risk for
obesity and this helps with irritability
so this is helping people who are Irabu
it's not very specific certainly the
major issue in autism which is the the
social problem and that's something
people the drug companies especially are
targeting right now along with other
researchers other medications are really
used to treat associated conditions you
can use stimulants for attentional
problems they work but they have a
probably higher rate of side-effects
than in the typical population I
mentioned anxiety and depression of the
SSRIs
keep in mind cognitive behavior therapy
can also work for anxiety and depression
and we have good data for that and we
have modifications of CBT specific to
children adolescents and adults with
autism the mild sedatives can sometimes
be helpful you have to be a little
careful because sometimes you get a
paradoxical response the person will get
much more agitated so if somebody
approaches me as a parent they want some
medicine to help a child get through a
dental visit I'll say okay we're gonna
try add a man here's the dose I want you
to try one dose at home to see what
happens first caveat don't create a bad
program with medications that ain't
gonna work
so always asking about the program be
aware the side-effects also be a little
bit of a detective yourself this is
probably less for primary care doctors
and more for people like me who get into
talking about medications in great
detail with parents if you hear for
example a woman who talked to me not too
long ago about her child and she said
linda was having trouble on the bus and
she wanted medications I said only on
the bus only on the bus so what are we
talking about we're not having a
medication discussion we're having a bus
discussion and they had put somebody on
the bus who was a screamer this kid did
not like sounds so it's the bus
discussion it's not a medication
discussion it's what can you do about
the bus that seems an autism for primary
care physicians especially to know
there's no evidence that vaccines cause
autism
there's no evidence that's I'm aerosol
which is used in a preservative the
vaccine which has not been taken out of
I think everything except multi dose
influenza many parents are now avoiding
vaccines because it's got an extreme
extreme popularity in terms of vaccines
causing autism there's absolutely no
data to show that we know that there's
an increased risk if you're vulnerable
to things like measles chicken pot
measles mumps rubella and people are
starting to see cases increased around
the country but we had our first case in
Brantford not too long ago my wife who's
a pediatrician she and her older partner
are the only people her practice who's
ever seen a case of measles
I think measles used to be not was gone
well it's now I'm making a comeback for
just this reason let me say a word about
complementary alternative treatments by
definition they're not proven treatments
there's a little data mostly anecdotal
they're very frequently used
complementary means in addition is
something that's been proven to work
good school program alternative means
instead of and that's where you have to
be really careful if parents are
pursuing treatments have not shown been
shown to work and they're doing that the
expensive treatments that have been
shown to work you really have to get
nervous sadly there are limited sources
of information for parents and
professionals on these people have been
making an effort in recent years is a
good chapter in the handbook of autism
on complementary treatments there's a
good resource online sadly it's called
quack watch but I'll give you some
information about complementary
treatments there's also at least one or
two now books on the topic that provide
well just descriptions of the treatment
what the evidence is pro and con so it's
a way for parents to get information
there's a lot of information out there
in the internet that's unfortunately not
very high quality which is why we're
trying to do videos like this there are
a couple of books I mentioned the
controversial therapies for
developmental disabilities more and more
of the practice guidelines are
specifically talking about treatments
and saying what the level of evidence is
now keep in mind something can be you
can pick any topic let's say music
therapy music's great piano lessons are
great they can be therapeutic in terms
of therapy part there's very limited
data that doesn't mean you can't do it
it's just its choice but don't think
it's going to cure your child's autism
so again it's that kind of issue that
things can be helpful but you have to
have a little bit of judgment of this
and it's easy to kind of go overboard
very quickly unfortunately we talked
about autism interventions we're getting
towards the end I mentioned the big
change in 1975 public law 94-142 autism
has to be treated in schools and we've
now seen that planning and appropriate
intensive interventions for social
difficulties can make a big difference
for many children I mentioned this
report earlier from the National
Research Council it went through all ten
programs in the country at that point
and had data talked about the
similarities and differences it
recommended on balance for preschool
children about 25 hours a week of
programming this could be in the home it
could be in a center and again there are
lots of shifting sands in this area but
this was a very influential book and
we're just talking about running a
commentary on what's happened in the
and the years since this volume came out
but the book says basically this autism
is a disorder that impacts development
interferes with learning on the other
hand development happens from the point
of view of treatment our strategy is
this we try to nm minimize negative
effects autism hands-on learning and
maximize as much as we can ways for
children to learn from the world a more
typical and more efficient and effective
ways and that's the secret that's easier
said than done
but that's it in a nutshell and the good
news is we are seeing some differences
in terms of outcome I emphasize I'm
cherry-picking these data the first set
of studies good fair and poor outcome
the first studies good means you're
independent and self-sufficient as an
adult fair means semi independent poor
means you're in 24/7 residential care
and you can see the first set of studies
starting with I think Leo Connors 1956
kids did not do well about five percent
of kids on average had a good outcome
and then he notice I stopped in 1974 cuz
I'm stopping as public law 94-142 kicks
in I wait 15 years and pick up the next
set of studies and look what's happened
we're seeing more kids have a good
outcome we're now having kids go to
college this is a new problem it's a
happy new problems have I've had a
student in my class as his doctoral
partland who self-identified as having
autism which is again it's great it's a
new problem it's a great new problem to
have but we have to think about what are
we gonna do to be able to accommodate
their needs so I want to close we have
time for a few questions
I mentioned the far fun in the man
foundation the Associates of the Child
Study Center the University which was a
great job in supporting people like guy
who's filming and his office and all my
colleagues whose work I'm drawing upon
for this presentation so thank you very
much we'll have time for questions
whoops I got my gift file here so I want
to end with a Yale bulldog so thanks I
hope you haven't been put to sleep
and we've just put up for one second the
first set of references then up up
another set of references so thanks very
much